et c'est cette énergie de cette maman
qui m'a donné envie de me dire il faut y
aller il faut continuer
notre hôtel samedi 20h ce soir Dominique
belle bonsoir
Dominique vous êtes là fondatrice de
l'association Les Petits Princes qui
réalisent les rêves d'enfants gravement
malade vous êtes une bonne fée et cela
depuis 27 ans grâce à vous aujourd'hui
plus de 5000 rêves d'enfants ont été
exaucés vous nous raconterez votre
histoire à 20h
[Musique]
Dominique Baye rebondoire
vous êtes la fondatrice de l'association
des Petits Princes qui réalisent les
rêves d'enfants gravement malade plus de
5000 à ce jour alors vous êtes né le 31
juillet 1956 à Amiens dans la Somme
votre père était expert-comptable votre
mère femme au foyer et un jour vous avez
à peine 7 ans vous sautez d'une armoire
sur un lit vous vous brisez le genou
direction l'hôpital la blessure tourne
mal la gangrène ronge votre jambe on
parle d'amputation et c'est comme ça que
vous découvrez la souffrance
hospitalière vous dites la nuit il y
avait que des cris de souffrance en fait
on est en 63 il est évident que il y
avait pas toutes ces approches
aujourd'hui psychologiques qui peuvent
soutenir donc ça fait partie de ma vie
mais vous êtes d'une nature
formidablement positive Dominique et
malgré votre genou mal soigné et le
scepticisme de votre entourage
vous vous accrochez et vous devenez prof
de gym en Grèce l'été et monitrice de
ski l'hiver dans les Alpes c'est
à dire et grâce à ça donc j'ai découvert
la montagne et je je me suis dit malgré
cet handicap je crois que je peux aimer
le sport je peux m'accrocher à quelque
chose qui va me permettre en fin de
compte d'être comme n'importe qui c'est
une vie dilique qui va durer 10 ans et
c'est en novembre
1997 que tout bascule en lisant Le
Figaro Magazine vous tombez sur un
reportage consacré à une association
américaine qui a exaucé les vœux de
trois enfants atteints du cancer en les
emmenant au cirque vous dites il
respirait le bonheur alors qu'il vivait
des choses extrêmement douloureuses le
lendemain vous décidez de faire la même
chose à l'époque 31 ans alors les
premières années c'est la galère
heureusement vous bénéficiez Dominique
d'un soutien d'envergure le service
d'oncologie de l'hôpital Robert Debré
qui réagit très vite en fait à vos
demandes alors le premier rêve réalisé
par l'association c'est celui d'Amandine
10 ans elle veut rencontrer Françoise Le
Grey danseuse étoile de l'Opéra de Paris
vous décidez de lui faire la surprise
alors vous la prenez à l'hôpital au
début elle a peur elle croit qu'on
l'emmène dans un autre hôpital tout à
fait tout à fait c'était étonnant parce
que à fois qu'on cachait les rêves pour
faire une surprise en fin de compte on
s'est aperçu par la suite qu'il fallait
que l'enfant le vivent déjà avant voilà
et donc ça a été absolument magique
l'accueil parce que elle visite l'opéra
elle rencontre Françoise Le Grey qui lui
offre ses chaussons voilà
et Françoise Leclerc écrit un petit mot
sur les chaussons oui ce qui était
formidable c'est que on ne se rend pas
compte mais la dédicace de Françoise Le
Grey a permis à cet enfant de mettre ses
petits chaussons de danse à l'hôpital
sur son lit et toutes les infirmières
les médecins lui demandaient mais
qu'est-ce que tu as vécu et du coup ça
lui permettait de penser à autre chose
que la maladie et puis surtout de lui
donner cette énergie supplémentaire pour
se battre malheureusement Amandine
mourra quelques temps plus tard un jour
vous rencontrez un enfant dont le rêve
et d'enregistrer un disque alors quand
vous entrez dans la chambre d'hôpital
vous le voyez que des tringles carrément
dans la tête vous avez larmes aux yeux
et là vous vous demandez si vous allez
pouvoir continuer alors ce qui m'a
permis à ce moment-là de continuer c'est
cette maman qui avait le même âge que
moi qui m'a rattrapé dans le couloir qui
m'a pris par l'épaule et qui m'a dit
merci
ça faisait trois mois que je ne voyais
plus mon enfant sourire et c'est cette
énergie de cette maman qui m'a donné
envie de me dire il faut y aller il faut
continuer malheureusement le petit
garçon
décédera avant la réalisation de son
rêve mais vous lui aviez rendu le
sourire ce qui est déjà une victoire
importante c'est là que vous décidez
parce que c'est dur de suivre une
psychothérapie vous avez besoin de
raconter vous voulez mieux mieux mieux
mieux cerner comment pouvoir avancer
dans la durée sans vous abîmer
alors parmi vos souvenirs il y a aussi
Corentin alors lui Corentin son rêve
c'était de conduire un camion poubelle
c'est extraordinaire et il a aussi
conduit un TGV oui dans la notion du
suivi votre objectif c'est de réaliser
plusieurs rêves parce que vous dites un
enfant ne doit jamais cesser de rêver on
va intervenir surtout en fonction de
l'évolution de la maladie il faut pas
que on soit des Père Noël ou prendre la
place des parents donc ça correspond
vraiment à une phase soit de traitement
ou d'hospitalisation il y a aussi ce
petit garçon atteinte de la maladie
d'éléphant man il avait eu 50 opérations
en 12 ans cette pauvre enfant et lui
rêvait de rencontrer Barthès le goal de
l'équipe de France en 98 et quand il
rencontre Barthès Barthez lui offre ses
gants de Gaulle c'était un enfant qui
était rejeté à l'école par rapport à sa
pathologie donc c'était un enfant qui
était tout le temps isolé et quand il
est revenu qu'il a raconté dans la cour
de l'école son rêve au départ on ne le
croyait pas quand il a montré les gants
tout le monde l'enviait et il est devenu
un enfant comme un autre presque la
mascotte d'un groupe qui le rejetait et
sa maman je peux vous dire me la
raconter en pleurant parce qu'il y avait
une émotion forte c'est énorme de
pouvoir être reconnu de retrouver une
identité d'enfant et d'être comme
n'importe quel enfant qui a des rêves
au total
Petit Prince a réalisé
5000 rêves alors parmi ceux-ci nager
avec les dauphins conduire une voiture
de rallye
rencontrer Donald
vivre une journée de vrais pompiers
rencontrer Zidane
faire du cheval
faire de l'hélicoptère
faire un tour en avion
rencontrer au mars
rencontrer le Père Noël
allez au Festival de Cannes voilà les
rêves que vous réalisez bravo
vous réalisez environ un rêve par jour
et vous dites j'ai la chance de
m'approprier le bonheur des autres c'est
mon moteur
une association petit prince qui font un
travail extraordinaire moi je voudrais
les saluer leur rendre hommage ce soir
parce que ils vont vous regarder bien
évidemment et je voudrais saluer Arnaud
qui a réalisé un rêve avec une petite
princesse et je suis ravie de d'être en
face de lui pour leur merci
alors
je ne sais pas
si vos petits malades auraient envie de
rencontrer Thierry Ardisson j'en sais
rien mais si un jour il y en a qui vous
dit ça m'étonnerait mais s'il y en a une
qui vous dit mon rêve c'est de rentrer
tir Ardisson je suis d'accord merci
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu